à
[Musique]
les derniers mètres j'en pouvais plus
j'avançais plus mais je les voyais seul
but c'était d'attendre la plage
[Musique]
bateau qui me suit avec un équipage donc
sur le bateau généralement prendre un
médecin mais mon père et ma mère qui me
ravitaille j'avais un ami qui met des
engrenages et avec moi une heure une
demi heure par dont toutes les heures et
demie moi je le suive le bateau je
restais à cinq mètres environ du bateau
et il y avait aussi un observateur qui
valide ma traversée et qui note
absolument tout ce qu'on fait
[Musique]
plongé dans une eau à 17 18 degrés il
refroidit très très vite et la seule
barrière contre le refroidissement du
corps c'est justement la grèce en
général les gens le font en maillot de
bain parce que c'est comme ça c'est la
tradition veut que ça se passe comme ça
pour le faire en maillot de bain
j'aurais dû prendre quinze à 20 kilos
du coup je les traversées en combinaison
[Musique]
au final on a récolté beaucoup d'argent
grâce aux sponsors et on avait assez
pour faire la traversée sans le
crowdfunding du coup on a décidé de
reverser la totalité de la cagnotte à
une association
[Musique]
quand on fait un projet sportif on a
besoin d'argent mais on est on est on
n'a pas besoin en fait de cet argent à
proprement parler c'est pour notre sport
pour ce qu'on veut mais de l'argent on
ne manque pas on ne manque pas autant
que ceux qui sont les plus démunis quand
on a l'occasion de pouvoir aider les
gens comme ça faut pas hésiter il faut
le faire quand c'est pour ça que j'y
suis allé